DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge, and this is
"Google Root Access," the show
for startups.
Today, we're going to talk about
social design patterns
and how you can build your
application to elicit the kind
of emotional response that
you're looking for.
I have a special guest,
Nazmul Idris.
Nazmul is a developer advocate
for Google and focused on
Android, and specifically,
user experience.
Welcome, Naz.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Thank you.
DON DODGE: So last time, we
talked a little bit about user
experience and design, and we
touched briefly on social
design experiences
and patterns.
So let's go a little deeper
on that today.
So what do you mean by social
design patterns, and
how does that work?
NAZMUL IDRIS: So as applications
evolve over time,
and the expectations
that users have of
applications change--
like, if you consider there's
hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of applications
in the app stores today.
In order to deliver a more
compelling experience, it's
important not just to deliver a
set of features but also to
use your portable identity to
make the user feel at home in
your application.
Not only that, but also use
the information in your
Circles to actually make them
feel like they're not alone in
your application.
So those two things are, in my
opinion, as time progresses,
going to be a requirement for
most applications to have.
So for example, let's say I've
downloaded this awesome game.
And it's a multiplayer game.
I could play it by myself,
which is interesting.
But if it's multiplayer, and
I'm signed in, and you're
signed, and we're in each
other's Circles, then it might
say, hey, would you like
to play a game of
whatever with Don?
It's like, yeah, sure.
So those are the kind of
engagements that would not
happen without taking into
account the social connections
that people have.
So there's a couple barriers
to entry, typically.
And that is that, when an
application is asking someone
for something as precious as
their identity, people tend to
be skeptical.
So it's really important for
applications or application
developers to tell the user,
first of all, why they need to
sign in and what benefits it
will unlock, and also do it at
the right time.
Like once they've gotten in-- in
this example of the game, I
need to play the game by myself
for a little bit to see
that even like it and if I
want to engage further.
Then it should tell me, hey,
if you sign in, you
could play with Don.
Well, actually, it wouldn't
know that you are in there
unless I sign in.
But it could say something
like, if you sign in, you
could play with your friends.
And if I sign in, it's like,
hey, would you like
to play with Don?
That is a much better flow,
if you will, for that
application.
DON DODGE: So you mentioned
the creepy factor once.
So people who have social
applications generally believe
that, OK, I'm going to interact
with friends.
But you mentioned the creepy
factor where the app knows
things about you before you
really get into it.
So how do you navigate that line
between being progressive
disclosure and the
creepy factor?
NAZMUL IDRIS: So all good
intentions can be perceived
negatively if they're not framed
in the correct context.
And so something that is an
amazing feature, which is a
very deep integration with
something, the user can
perceive it to be creepy.
And so it's really
important to--
the progressive disclosure
is key.
You want the user to become
familiar with
the application gradually.
And as they become more
and more familiar,
start unlocking features.
So if you had done this upfront,
if you condense that
timeline, and let's say that
you launch the application
that says, sign in
with all your
social identity providers.
Your reaction is going to be,
wow, why are you trying to
steal all my information?
But if you do it slowly and
say, hey, here's the
application.
Here's your first experience.
It's great.
If you want to do
more, sign in.
Just sign in with Facebook.
OK, fine.
I sign in with Facebook.
I'm actually enjoying the
application, and it says, hey,
if you would like to bring in
friends from other social
networks, feel free to do so.
And then you're like, OK, I'll
link it to my Google+ account.
I'll link it to whatever
other--
like I can link it to my GitHub
account, my LinkedIn
account, my Twitter account.
And then if that starts
unlocking really, really cool,
amazing experiences for
this application--
because now the number of people
I can interact with has
now increased, which is adding
value to me and how I
experience this thing--
it's no longer creepy.
It's actually a value add.
DON DODGE: So when you say
progressive disclosure, you
mean that in terms of if you
have lots of features,
disclose the easy ones first and
get them engaged and get
an experience going before
you get into the
deep and complex features.
But you also mean, in the social
context, when you ask
for the account creation and
what information you ask for--
so progressively do that.
Not all up front.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
Because if you do it
all up front--
because as humans, we all have
emotional reactions to things.
We're just a bag of sensors,
and how information is
collected by those sensors is
how we perceive things.
So even if you're doing the same
number of things over a
period of time, the
timing matters.
And it's not just with
applications.
It matters with just about
any human interaction.
If you consider, like, dating.
If you do the wrong things at
the wrong times, the outcomes
will be very different.
Even though if you look at it
over a period of time, it's
like, hey, I have, like, 10
actions I've done, and the
outcome was good.
But the timing in which and the
sequence in which you did
them was critical.
And so application developers
really need to think about the
human element that is half
of the context of the
interaction.
So the human element is
interacting with the software,
or the digital stuff.
And so the digital stuff has
to understand how the human
element is going to react in
order to deliver a good
experience versus a bad one.
So the number of features
might be the same.
The outcomes might be the
same, ultimately.
But how I perceive it determines
greatly what the
outcome is.
DON DODGE: Is it possible to
know the sequence in advance?
Is it possible to model
all of this out
before you start building?
Or do you need user experience,
like baby users,
to figure it out?
NAZMUL IDRIS: I think that you
can make certain guesses,
because we've talked about use
cases and personas and so on.
But those are guesses.
I mean, they are models
of things.
You could create prototypes.
Once you create the prototypes,
you have to get it
in front of users and
get them to test it.
There's no substitute
for user testing.
And then prototyping
is critical.
So you roll out a prototype.
You do some user testing
very rapidly.
You get your feedback, and
then you iterate that.
If you do not adopt that lean
model, it's very, very
difficult to take into account
the human element, because the
human element is, by its very
nature, complicated.
DON DODGE: So the key points--
progressive disclosure, getting
features out there in
progress, and user experience
design.
Try to do as much of that
up front as possible.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
And user testing.
DON DODGE: Excellent.
Well, thank you very much.
Thank you for joining us.
Join us again next time when
we discuss other issues of
importance to startups.
I have a special offer for
"Google Root Access" viewers.
We're offering a $2,000 credit
on the Google Cloud platform.
So if you're a developer who has
an application that uses
the cloud and a back end, you
can sign up for the Google
Cloud Platform, get started
quickly, and save $2,000 at
the same time.
The instructions are
on the screen.
They're also in the description
of the YouTube video.
Thanks for joining us, and
see you again next time.